of Ramsey solutions Andrew and Valerie
are with us hey guys how are you hey
Dave you Francie welcome welcome it's an
honor to have you where you guys from
Orange County California all the way to
Nashville yes sir that's a bit of a haul
just for you
well we're honored to have you and here
to do your debt-free scream yes sir they
are and how much have you paid off
we paid off fifty-two thousand dollars
in four years while cash flowing sixty
five thousand in our dream wedding and
two masters degrees whoa
Wow making what kind of money during
this four years okay I'm the nerd on
average 57,000 combined household income
but now after all the debt is paid we
are north of 120 I went out and bought a
bigger shovel ah okay called a master's
degree yeah absolutely very cool what
y'all do for a living
well I now AM an intelligence analyst
for a large government organization very
cool and I work for a local government
agency as a management aide oh very cool
good for you guys so what kind of debt
was the 52,000 well it started off being
my car credit cards and my student loans
oh my my my when did you all get married
2012 three years ago yeah but this took
four years correct so the first year we
kept everything separate and he was
about to deploy overseas and so we were
engaged engaged before that happened and
one of the things your name did come up
on the second date that's wrong on so
many levels oh but it was life-changing
you know she basically said hey you know
he wanted separate bank accounts and
that was kind of a second date well we
weren't we knew we were gonna get
married pretty early on Wow okay so by
the time that we started dating
intentionally I mean everything was
separate but we started getting into the
the meat and potatoes of this and
he went serving overseas he would just
hear horror stories of spousal wipeouts
you know what while they're serving
their country and so he was very set on
having his hers an hour budget and I
think I said something along the lines
of if you don't trust your wife to
handle your finances while you're
serving our country you have no business
marrying her yeah you kind of get
straight to the jugular you're safer
deployed well when it's meant to be it's
meant to be there you go the year before
we got married I actually had the honor
and he he trusted me through
accountability with his parents that
while he was serving I actually was able
to handle his finances with his money no
one to help to help do that so by the
time that we got married it was pretty
easy to just combine and you know go
forth and conquer wow that's that's
pretty cool that's a long step right
there I mean it's too far for as far
from when we get married yours mine and
ours too all the way before we're
married I'm gonna let you handle this
that's that's a big leap it was worth it
and you know it's nice to have a
secretary essentially back home while
I'm focusing on the mission at hand so
unable to come back home absolutely yeah
I keep [ __ ] keeps your head in the game
which keeps you alive it's a hobby
mission a mission readiness is a big
deal yeah excellent well good job you
guys congratulations so mainly it was
Andrews debt that he was working on then
you get married and the two of you plow
into it is that how the story goes more
or less I mean it was kind of hard
getting going
you know we paid off the truck before we
got married and then those student loans
just stuck around and you know I took on
well she took on several jobs Wow and I
was volunteering at two different places
plus my Army National Guard stuff and so
you know giving away 40 plus hours of
free time trying to get into the job
that I wanted to and eventually it paid
off just happened to after we got that
free okay well that worked out one of
your rants actually really inspired that
instead of going after a Jo B it was as
long as we're we're handling this as
long as we're able to make it
to do this and so he was volunteering I
mean he showed his work ethic is second
to none he would show up every day like
it was a full-time job and even 3
o'clock in the morning when they needed
help you know to just help him out and
it is bad experience that truthfully
landed him his his dream company and boy
those floodgates opened after yeah bad
that's very cool it's a whole different
kind of investing right there yeah have
congratulations you guys very well done
so what do you tell people the secret to
paying off fifty-two thousand dollars in
debt in your first three merry years of
marriage is well I think accountability
is really a major thing I know there are
times where we didn't want to do the
extra job sometimes it's the job is
maybe not so much fun but it's hey this
is what we're doing this is how we're
gonna do it let's do it together
and so being accountable to each other
was a major thing to do yeah for me it
was hand plow push it was just keep one
foot after the other and and he is such
a huge encouragement and when I say like
he was you know a strength behind this
sometimes he'd be holding me up
literally the other thing that we used I
think as a key is we called it do not
pass go and that was with all of our
extra side jobs they weren't in the
budget because we weren't counting on it
and so we would call it a do not pass go
so as soon as that money came in it was
do not pass go do not collect $200 do
not go out to eat you go straight to
where you belong ok so keep the money
flowing towards the goal yes keep the
money flowing towards the goal and no
matter what you're making no matter what
the source of the money is where it
comes from keep it flowing towards a
goal right that intense focused like
that and you obviously have worked well
together that's a big deal yeah I think
so I mean the budget meetings the most
difficult part was actually defining the
budget I grew up a certain way with my
dad he designed a budget for us and I
saw it a certain way she saw it a
different way
we communicate and listen differently
and so trying to put mesh that together
where it works at the same time when
that was diplomatic
Excel became one of my side jobs so I
know it's not gonna work like that but
so thank you for every dollar because
that that really does help fight it I
mean our Excel budget is pretty there's
lots of colors on it and stuff yeah yeah
every dollar just really works yeah and
you can carry it around in your pocket
with the iPhone app and all right very
cool well congratulations you guys how
does it feel to have accomplished this
this early in the marriage we're stoked
I mean we have a life ahead of us and
you know we already are good way into
our next baby step with saving up our
three to six months emergency fund thank
you to the California fires that I was
mobilized for you know and we're just
going straight forward going at it so we
could see fund the fire fund sorry go it
was funded by very cool will
congratulations you two all right Andrew
and Valerie rock stars Los Angeles
California fifty-two thousand dollars
plus cash flowing degrees and everything
else to the tune of another sixty five
thousand over four years making fifty
seven to now making 120 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
I love it oh that's fun
that is seriously fun congratulations
you guys